en tout les cornes et on est content
voilà joey starr deuxième temps me l'ont
dit non
[Musique]
elle a fait danser une génération la
mienne surtout j'ai 36 ans aujourd'hui
et je pensais le break dance il ya bien
longtemps que je sais pas s'il y aller
jusque là qu'il nous faut pour être un
de nos fans mais donc bah vous êtes au
courant qu ici ici vous avez vous avez
brûlé des neurones non c'est en tout cas
respect un peu beaucoup beaucoup
vous ce soir avec nous la non gestion
d'affaires tu le semblable
[Musique]
c'est là à prendre de nouvelles parts
dans lan suparimuk tonnes portative
j'écris tomber
key west
[Musique]
kent wells
reichardt tu connais sahwa
[Musique]
celle là et gardent bien sûr c'est
l'invité suivant bien tu te mets là elle
est bien t'as jamais jamais il va faire
saliver j'aimerais c'est un rebelle
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu